pillola rossa pillola blu in base alla
pillola che sceglie vedrai quanto sono
lunghi gli episodi di è più visto su
questo canale è che i ragazzi siamo
ritornati appunto su matt reeves con il
duecentesimo e dei 15
cominciamo 4 ho notato che se avete
fatto ci avete fatto caso nel tempo è
più iss ha peggiorato la grafica cioè si
vede molto peggio come possibile questa
cosa vabbè saab space e misseri quel un
emissario del sub spazio questo è il
nome del livello per vediamo
lo fa col demonio una cosa aiuto a utah
jazz io il nuovo lì dietro non capisco
niente di che la loro rubrica le cose no
c'è un tizio qua è un palloncino delio
quello a dio
sto calciando gente come se non ci fosse
un domani ma va bene
è difficilissimo che lei sta roba
son of music e per favore che mi sta
stordendo le orecchie le membra allora
ragazzi rispetto a prima sono molto più
carico
continuo a calciare gente invece la
dubbia madonna che questo channel non
c'è la spada c'è un cannone raggi laser
schiaccio qui dove mi sta portando sale
e vabbè paese c'è un cuba parco funziona
deve fissare che appunto veterinario in
questo gioco di una caciotta in faccia
cos'è una cantata una botta col rapper
come faccio ad andare qua sopra non vi
possa arrampicare sono il padre io che
non so se hai presente non si può devo
ai at t sono spezzato la schiena fa
niente tutto a posto è un massaggio
alternativo lo conosco giorgio e lo
faccio mi aspetta madonna cell opposta
ok non so se avete presente valli che
porta all'inizio io c'ho mal di schiena
si vede proprio insomma di ti aspetta un
attimo non mi tirare le cose con
l'arrivo aia
e va bene va bene mi sembra un pò li
rende impossibile però però è fatto
veramente bene su cui non si può dire
niente porca vacca kikwete bravo
complimenti hard bike park opaco o
riesco a fare un qualcosa c'è ma alcune
da un posto di tempo che non lo faccio
però più che sembra tranquillo infatti
venirmi è proprio sereno che le sue
madonne che volo
madonna che salta in framing beh vabbè
madonna mi sono schiantate i duemila
all'ora contro muro tutto a posto
ragazzi comunque posso guidare il treno
subito non leggo neanche le istruzioni
perché io ne so io lo so e le faccio
back flip col treno o dio sto male
in questo momento che la nuova aspettare
che gli eventi è tutto a posto tanto è
talmente grosso suo treno che guarda
come sono messo guarda la posizione di
nonno ciak vi prego
cos'è sta roba
prese la uil sono visto
comunque era talmente grosso suo treno
che non poteva succedermi niente molto
figo molto carino e skydrive scappa dai
coltelli
mi sembra un po
eccessiva questa comprò vediamo secondo
me vanno troppo veloci non posso fuggire
pro cipro
[Musica]
proprio lui ragazzi comunque ragazzi ho
appurato che mi mancano gli impossible
quindi adesso faremo gli impossible e
quindi facciamo csp impossible borg
quali stessa disney questo potrebbe
essere impossibile ma che
facciamo presto potrebbe essere
possibile ma che è impossibile dei favi
non c'è niente di impossibile per
rifarvi ragazzi proprio niente rock
swing extreme questo è uno comunque
ragazzi adesso farò altri imposti male
perché non può che non ne faccio ma
soprattutto anche i rock swing non ne
faccio non fosse magari chiedendo di
prendere la corda bravo
solito le orecchie mm non meno meritata
perché seguite il video di api che cazzo
riguarda 300.000 21 tutti lo alla bit
faranno anche avanti senza ritenta tanto
liuc che è successo ma se io andassi
perfetto la neve batumi su ma turno come
mi sono salvato devo andare dritto e di
testa mi spiace perché purtroppo dal dar
come vorrebbe come vorrebbe farmi
trenino su
questo gioco e non l'ho più fatto nel
tempo per un motivo adesso ve lo spiego
ma anzi forse non c'è bisogno lo spieghi
beck perfetto
stavolta siamo entrati giusti laga siamo
entrati giusti di testa
[Musica]
a me ma scusa io ho fatto tutto il mio
hanno fatto niente stavolta cioè io mi
metto esattamente come dice lui sto
fermo perché sto fermo che doveva e poi
muoio ma allora alla che dici
ma sarà morto c'è il traguardo che però
qua ma non è questo casino perché questo
guarda la lia lapini ma va bene va bene
che è il giocatore che gioca allo
ragazzi prima deve essere l'impossible
riescono in qualche modo a essere un po
originali perché comunque no non è del
rating ma facciamo si può mettere nell
ultima settimana di miu miu miu verso il
prossimo ed è veramente noi possiamo
pregare 2016 li ho fatti tutti ma
sicuramente a noi piace possiamo fare
questo lo vedo già più normale tipo
un'impressione più classico mi ha
allagato anche il computer da 20mila
euro però vabbè
saltare quella lì non ragazzi possibile
aspettativa questo è veramente assurdo
ma se mollo il poco di buono no cacchio
fai non è vero questo caso non ho
toccato il traguardo è una vittoria
super fake ma lo accetto la accetto
volentieri il prossimo al 100 che c'è
questo proprio non si può fare se
scritto cento per cento però non è uno
spy phone questo è un iphone app che
importiamo cento cioè non ci passi li
non lo so ragazzi questo si può
veramente fare cioè come cacchio fai
[Applauso]
ragazzi l'ha fatta 9 pazzesco ma è pur
sempre a fare una roba a parte quel sito
in in gara
non è non è la weening aerea va bene
volevo provare a passare all'esterno
infatti che mi sembra un po più facile
comunque si può fare sono sta qua due
anni lo fa ci voglio solo due anni
out of memory ma cosa ragazzi
perché è qui che stoffa è il livello più
pesante di etnico in società veramente
come grazie possibile il prossimo 50 per
cento cambiamo perché effettivamente
voli prima non era fattibile facciamo
questi non
vedi che subito abbiamo trovato la
vittoria e siamo a posto l'impossible
dei trans
ho scelto
non ho fatti valere bravo a quando
finisce non finisce più
non ci posso credere solo porto
all'ultimo ma dai raga dai non ci posso
credere
saturare sono molto all'ultimo artico
del demonio maledetti incastrato dentro
è più che si aspetta
buona settimana ma se jacobs
no l'ho toccato noto caffè gianpi replay
per favore anzi lo faccio io quando
faccio io l'ho toccato lo toccasse
rischio
guarda guarda guarda
è lo toccava l'avete visto adesso tocca
io l'ho toccato comunque ragazzi spero
che oggi vi sia piaciuto questo era
primis dei semi piaciuto come avete
lasciato mettono i viaggi iscritti al
canale e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video belle ragazze
[Musica]